what's up guys this week's Bitcoin
updates a little inside baseball for you
as we know in the market there's only
been one data point that lots of people
have been talking about it's that hash
rate hit an all-time high bitcoin's
price dropped 70 over the last year but
hash rate continues to go up but in the
recordings for our podcast I had
conversations with two different people
that said the same exact thing even
though we're in this deep bear Market
there are institutions that are chomping
at the bit ready to get back into the
game the first individual was David
Mercer from lmax and he said the six
major Banks they're ready to go as soon
as they get a green light from the
regulatory environment I can name
probably six of the largest banks in the
world who if if and when they get the
green for go sign I think they can be
active throughout all the markets in
crypto within a month the second was
Braden Anderson who works at the largest
law firm in the world said the same
thing the big institutions they're ready
to go but forget even the things that
I've heard forget the things that people
said on the podcast I personally this
week talk to multiple organizations some
of the biggest asset managers in the
world they all have teams focused on
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they're
hiring they're building out those teams
and they're trying to figure out what
they're going to do some of them want to
build products other of them want to
drive Revenue through Services related
to the industry and others just simply
want to make it easier for investors to
allocate to the space regardless of what
happens to price in the short term one
thing is for certain the big financial
institutions they're here they're
building teams internally and they are
going all in on bitcoin and crypto that
might not actually help the price in the
short term but that tells me over a long
period of time this industry is not
going anywhere and that means that you
at home you take a deep breath chill out
and remember the long-term Vision gives
you a huge advantage over the people who
don't have patience and simply are
focused on day-to-day price movements
these weekly updates are brought to you
by FTX click on the link in the
description make sure that you go check
them out they have fees as low as 85
percent cheaper than their editors I'll
see you guys next Saturday I hope that
you guys are enjoying these weekly
updates